I think she took two too much off the
bottom really yeah so you know what I
took a little too much off of what tip
whoa
you tipped the GU the cameras on I
didn't mean to say something so rude oh
whoa-oh-oh on Luke oh forget that happen
hello hello welcome to this video it's
off that's a new catchphrase place know
what's of course um but do they forget
but if you don't remember us because
you're an idiot
we are great the memory of hot and my
name is Claude Doris trampled it's the
family name
I am main reason and she I tell you what
light of my life
pain of my ash I haven't heard that one
I made it up
I've been working on new quotes to get
him ported into pillows oh my name is
Margaret Cho no relation no relation I
didn't even know there was a possible
relation didn't even know there was a
possible relation with Margaret Cho when
she was Margaret Cho until the tumor we
went to Boca Raton for some vacation up
and you know we have a condo now we
split it it's timeshare we split it with
five other families yes we went out to
dinner and we're in the Hard Rock Cafe
now we get there and they're like we're
like Margaret Cho and they're like all
right this way yeah and they sit us in
the night the nicest food no it was
right underneath um a bass guitar from
Incubus yeah I think it was incubate
from in Quebec and then they said when
is Miss Cho gonna be here and we were
like she's right here yeah I'm right
here yeah like I like some shrimp
cocktail please clean your glasses yeah
and then we realized there's the famous
one there's a famous one we work in a
library we work at a library it is a
fancy affair
and speaking of fancy affair normally we
come on here and we we love to complain
I tell you what there's nothing plain
about complaining whoa
I'm telling you I've worked out so many
phrases my house is just gonna be a pile
of your your hands are gonna be just so
tired by the end of the summer I got a
couple girls who are gonna do it for me
what you're outsourcing I'm outsourcing
whoa go out door thing will say normally
we do something that you guys all know
and love to great-aunts Ram
Wow Wow you know harmonies more than
that the blacks take up
they got this harmony we I we got set
seven Sundays holidays
we're taking an trance up a notch we are
going to be reviewing sama blockbusters
oh we look great in we look then oh do
you wanna look let's start talking about
some of the biggest summer blockbusters
that we want to talk about because you
know that in the summer is when they
pump out all those big bigger budge
action film yep every other thing has
the rock in it the other thing is the
rock in and except for us
oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh stones so technically
you are microscopic rocks in my bin my
body
yep okay looks like hell okay Captain
America Civil War I would like to know
mm-hmm is this about the actual Civil
War I don't think that they should start
teaching children that superheroes were
in the war when the only super heroes
that were in the war were nurses nurses
real Civil War had nurses this movie has
narcissist - it has a lot the arms the
other Avengers the only Avengers I know
about Oh revenge oh that's you because
you've never ever ever let go of a
grudge no no I got good grip Raj now
that was the movie whoa couldn't finish
it I want to see Captain America take on
the creepy long-haired girl from the
grudge
I'd only pay matinee twice but I thought
you next movie Independence Day
resurgence now this movie came out like
what ten years ago they're doing a
sequel 15 years later and you know what
what Will Smith hasn't aged a day
he's in it
it's about any aliens that come down to
earth okay on Independence Day do you
not think it's a little convenient Jeff
Goldblum in this one yes he is big-time
oh I know that's your sweet spot that's
just sweet oh wow I would eat a bloomin
onion you know what I mean oh he's very
sexy uh I'd like I'm in shock to say I'd
let him eat my bloomin onion I hope
nothing autumn resembles an onion
finding dory ah
I enjoyed Finding Nemo mm-hmm I would
like to know why these fish get lost so
much so much do they not have GPS
seriously what's going travel in school
like how how hard is it to not be able
to keep up with 900 other things that
look exactly like you and now they make
phones so that you can drop them in
water and they're fine yeah so they must
all have phones because lord knows we've
dropped some last time we went
snorkeling yep remember what happened
vaguely I blacked out I dropped my pager
oh that was such a bummer I went down I
thought sunfish I went to reach and then
my pager went down and I couldn't hold
my breath long enough to go down to get
it it was a tragedy it was a tragedy she
was out there for 72 hours before we
found us I did lose weighthow central
intelligence the rockin Kevin hot we
made it three home movies before the
rock turned out and before the people
that they compared us to the most turned
up
we're with him one more time that you
and I off the rock and Kevin high
generations the rock and Kevin Hart I'm
gonna lose my mind
the almost names maimry Kevin almost
enter Kevin she looks like a Kevin I
know we saw in the sonogram she was in
the sonogram and she was the relative
she was talking oh oh you reminded to
the little kid from home alone will name
you Kevin and then her name would have
been Kevin Hart could you imagine how
hard it would be working in Hollywood
with the name Kevin Hart if you're not
beat Kevin Hart wow you saved us
essential intelligence what's this about
I bet there's some high jinks I bet the
rock picks up Kevin hall like he's like
an adult baby I bet at one point they're
like we need to get in we need to get in
there you dress up like a kid but send
your kid oh I bet they switch clothes at
some point
Kevin hall it looks like you know the
kid at the end the big when he goes back
to being the case ghostbusters
I ain't afraid of no female Ghostbusters
wow there's so much controversy going
around and I like because people are
upset at its ladies as the Ghostbusters
it's little boys going oh don't back
with my toys stir upset the ladies are
wearing vacuums on their backs cleaning
things up oh I'm sorry
oh you leave small Wow you're gonna have
to bust those ghosts cuz you just killed
all the haters bang boom boy when you go
to the movies what do you get at the
concession stand what side you know like
a mortgage because it's so except oh I
don't water what are you talking about
oh you sneaking food I'll bring it in in
my bag what do you bring in I bring um
well I have like a low microwavable meal
that's with me that's Alfredo's really
good oh yeah the cheddar uh broccoli
potato Oh what everyone's jealous of you
and when you're sitting in the movies
yep and everyone see in their $80 pop
come on up and they look at you and
you're eating a potato and broccoli who
is this royalty right this is Regal
Cinemas yeah and then they get really
upset because I'm usually wearing my top
hat and they're like that's so that's in
my face when I go to the movies I like
to eat Mexican soldier felt what I do is
I put a bunch of like a whole entire
Mexican buffet in my purse I have a big
purse but then what I do is I borrow
memories dogs and i put the dog on top
when they say hey it smells like you got
are you sneaking in are you sneaking in
enchiladas uncle no it's this dog smell
uh-huh very vintage look you do it she's
doing an impression of someone watch and
finding Dory you can stick Kevin hot in
there well they give it to the movie
thank you guys to listen let us know
what you think of the movies or don't
let us know because you know we haven't
figured out how to reason we know and we
have a big summer reading list to get to
anyway yeah me
I know move it's a great but like really
to ball you know how I think we could
get kids to read what if we
designs uh-huh look colors like let's
say you have like gone with the wind'
said it's like Scarlett O'Hara and all
the guy what if we replace them with the
rock and kept Kevin Hart on all of them
all the classics on me on Juliet the
rock rock F cannot oh my god Of Mice and
Men
well clearly you know which ones which
on that yeah yikes not a good ending and
make sure that you go check out main
reach a no B oh yeah we what do we talk
about over there oh we talk about summer
barbecues I'm a barbecue um so we'll see
you guys next time
like and subscribe subscribe goodbye I
think we're off on putt oh it's all so
with all of that school yeah that's so
good ah whoa I can't believe those
idiots children's and watch this [ __ ]
what's that what's that the Virgin
Islands or was that Cozumel let us say
Virgin Islands Oh out they let you would
you did that the entire time I prefer
pages right you know and so it's
whenever Margaret and I wanted to hang
out she knows I'm not gonna answer my
phone I want her to page me we had a
cold
there was eight zero zero eight five
folks folks it looks the Pope's I was
like I'm gonna go out of my own I'm
gonna find some really nice coral reefs
when the boat is getting ready to leave
again just page me
yep just page me to let me know I was
the dumbest story but